guess who I saw today
yes
who I saw today
guess who I saw
today
I mean oh my goodness that's a sound I
could sleep to live to love to
everything to and that was the song
guess who I saw today and Grammy
nominated album
um linger a while there it is
she is a 23 year old Jazz sensation
whose voice has been compared to icons
like Sarah Von and Ella Fitzgerald and
she is also nominated in the prestigious
Best New Artist category for the Grammys
it's as big as it gets please welcome
Samara Joy
foreign
[Applause]
entry points into when I was doing uh
research for you was this video and it's
like the best way to get to know you can
I show it really quickly okay all right
you just found out that you were a
two-time Grammy nominee take a look
foreign
[Applause]
so before
um you even went to college you were
interested in jazz but you almost like
didn't pursue it how did like the
interest and yet the life path finally
come together how did it almost not come
together right I so I grew up in the
Bronx New York I grew up in America
um in a very musical family
um my dad plays bass my my grandparents
saying you know they had a choir called
to save it to Philadelphia so I grew up
around music pretty much all of my life
but
um I was in some like a sort of jazz
elective towards the end of high school
and I just learned a couple of songs for
the class it was nothing major but I
didn't feel the urge to pursue it um
until I realized that I had to make a
decision about college
um and I was like I don't know I want to
keep music in my life so I auditioned
for a state school here in New York
called SUNY Purchase at their great jazz
studies program I got in I was like kind
of I don't want to say rock bottom but I
was just like I didn't know anything you
know I was like pretty much I felt like
the only one there who was kind of just
starting really from zero
um but I'm thankful to have had you know
amazing professors and you know
supportive friends and everybody who
just kind of like I had like a crash
course on everything that I needed to
know for four years graduated in May of
2021 so congratulations thank you
and you like
to fame
um and a lot of it also was through Tick
Tock and I was actually curious what is
your advice for someone who is now
two-time Grammy nominated best new
artist of the year and like crushing it
it was a place where you could put
yourself out there any advice to people
I would say you know social media can be
very daunting because you feel like you
have to put on a certain image you feel
like you have to you know fit into a
certain box in order to like
succeed but I think Tick Tock was the
one place where I felt like I could just
be myself you know and just sing you
know I I can't dance and I can't you
know do all of the stuff you know that
that's on there but I just felt like if
I'm gonna use it I want to do it my way
I want to show my most authentic self I
want to share my passion share my music
and hopefully people will gravitate
toward it and they did well yeah and it
worked and is it true
at the last question that you like ROM
action comedies not just rom-coms but
action in the romantic comedies yes oh
my gosh my favorite genre because like
my mom she loves like the action stuff
but I'm like more of like the the
lovey-dovey person in the family so like
anything like this means war maybe a
little Never Been Kissed You know just
throw it in there you know but
by the way I write like literally you
said Never Been Kissed and I was like oh
into Josie grocery because I am her yes
I'm with you I love that genre of film
too you can go after this let's hi
everybody
now and up next someone in our audience
is going to go home with a very big
surprise I am so excited about this one
don't go anywhere
[Music]